dernière ligne droite pour le sport
olympique à moins de deux ans des Jeux
Olympiques le vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines accueilli une
journée de promotion au programme les 10
disciplines quincaillera le département
bah on apprend à faire des virages un
peu serrés à prendre des bosses comme il
faut et à
pédaler avec un BMX et l'allumer super
découverte de l'activité
très progressif on a pu apprendre en
confiance je crois les bases et puis
voilà découvrir un sport sympa des
baptêmes des démonstrations encadrées
par des sportifs de haut niveau et des
acteurs locaux je suis accompagnée par
le département et faire Bédié je
représente l'équipe de France
en boxe olympique et je suis aussi
directrice d'une association qui a pour
but de promouvoir le sport dans nos
quartiers
l'intérêt de ce sport c'est que tout le
monde peut le pratiquer tout à l'heure
on avait une petite deux trois ans qui
s'essayait il y avait une personne un
fauteuil cette journée était organisée
par le département des Yvelines avec
dans le viseur le vendredi 26 juillet
2024 date d'ouverture des Jeux d'été
c'est dans moins de 2 ans donc on lance
petit à petit cette événement
l'événement qui s'appelle destination
2024 c'est un événement qui a vocation
donc là c'est la première année cet
événement se déroulera aussi en 2023 et
en 2024 les Yvelines sont le troisième
département dans l'ordre d'organisation
des Jeux Olympiques Paris la
Seine-Saint-Denis les Yvelines où on a
cinq événements sur notre territoire et
donc on a voulu commencer à enclencher
le compte à rebours dans un peu plus de
660 jours les meilleurs athlètes
s'affront dans 32 disciplines olympiques
et paralympique première épreuve dans le
département le cyclisme sur route le 27
juillet